so
I I try to understand this FTX thing
I really am right
so if I got this straight and I watch
videos because I I did not care about
FTX I don't care about it I thought that
was a [ __ ] scam since day one to be
honest with you so I really didn't care
about it like like you know how many
[ __ ] coins I ignore you know what oh
yeah all the time so it's like whatever
I don't know but apparently this is a
big deal right so this Jewish guy named
what's his name um Sam bakeman freed yes
okay now what's his real name stop
saying joke names bro what what happened
that's that's his no oh yeah okay yeah
Jewish big Mick bankerson what's his
real name
it's hyphenated his dad's last name is
bankman and his mom's last name is
complicated it okay well anyway I'm
trying to understand I was trying to
understand so I watched a bunch of
videos about it a couple things I
learned crypto streamers [ __ ] cringe
they really are oh they're the worst
they look like they all look like she
left the steampunk Festival I don't know
what that's about but to be fair they
give some good information so from what
I gather from everything that I saw this
bankman freed guy
um let me actually pull a picture of him
up uh Sam bankman freed
um he started this coin right [ __ ] it
literally his name she's literally been
Goldman jewelry steam bro I know I know
I know it's ridiculous anyway Sam exit
scam scam exits Cam's a good one Sam
bankman 401K Steam
I think like some sort of some Canadian
province like put a bunch of investment
in it too and now they lost like a bunch
of the government lost money right they
call them the Social Security of
investment firms yeah seriously they
call me Kevin pension [ __ ] coin Goldman
Burger Steve
[Laughter]
I mean they call me soul trust fund
foreign
but you could call me IRA
so
anyway my name is Ira CDO Rothstein
proth Ira the first so I'm sure we're
gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] because I
don't understand this FTX thing to be
honest with you but first I don't either
that's why I'm just making up funny
Jewish names
it's called staying in your lane that's
what I'm doing good call
[Laughter]
did a handy dandy little chart and Show
links to make it easier for you I know
exactly what you're talking about Sylvia
I haven't even looked at it yet and I
know what chart it is that's a whole lot
of autism right there
what is that
Frankie what am I supposed to do with
this
I'm going to but what is this
this is insane
[Laughter]
okay first you can you explain what I'm
looking at I'm lost okay so I'll I'll
post a link to this and the the [ __ ]
chat okay and on the locals and stuff
this is actually a chart breaking down
all of the different connections of who
was the CEO of what and what was
partnered where between Almeida FTX and
a couple other uh all right sorry
explain it to me like it was five okay
energy where's potassium
it's not the periodic table God damn it
so there's this guy from this tribe
that's known for being trusted okay I
don't need you to go that I don't I
don't need you to go that far back I
don't need you to go that far back like
okay and I have a better chart
somebody was asking somebody was at
somebody was asking if that chart was
the healthcare.gov website it's not oh
[ __ ] I just signed us up for Obamacare
so
no that's a straight line so FTX was
this thing where he this guy was going
his idea was to invest 500 million not
invest but to to give 500 million
dollars to charity with his stupid coin
or whatever right except the X point so
then what started happening is is that
FTX gave a bunch of money to the
Democratic party like a lot like the
highest donator was yeah it was Soros
into them right them which same thing
um it's the same picture uh so yeah no
this is this guy this guy's just crypto
sorrows
so yes he serious many more than one way
he tell the train he's calling him Sam
overdraft fee
and then
over leverage the money
what you don't say yeah and then you
gotta over leverage in crypto in a
recession and then this was his CFO if
I'm correct no Caroline Ellison this is
a CFO this is in a Photoshop I know
people are saying it's no no no no no no
no no no this is real oh God real person
right no this is a real [ __ ] dude this
is this is why I wanted to talk about it
I don't care about the coin the people
that are involved in this are weird zoom
in on the teeth no please don't while
you have this on screen let me read one
of her Tumblr posts please please of
course it's Tumblr of course it's Tumblr
this is this is from her Tumblr trans
Ricky Berwick
the [ __ ] car battery exploded in her
face
look at my foreign
look I might not be a crypto person but
if you would have told me about a coin
and I looked it up and I go oh this is a
CFO I am not investing in this coin most
of the whole point of this coin is to
raise money for charity so it's a scam
yeah she said Batman building called
whole face
[Laughter]
oh God [ __ ] whole face is [ __ ]
funny
oh holy [ __ ] okay so anyway he fled the
country they don't know where he is oh I
know where he is he's in Argentina okay
he's hiding with the other with the
Argentine milkies yes maybe we need to
send our undercover got him hey there
Eliana I own the big I own a [ __ ] coin
the crashed an economy
so the Reason by the way how do you like
that jrc3 don't let that guy in not you
he
defrauded everyone's 401ks
anyway
so Virgie
saying posted a really good one her hair
looks like an old Thanksgiving wreath
I think it's all so what what's this
what's the same time do Jerry bankerman
what's his name again dude they actually
her hair actually looks like when you
like when you spray weeds and then come
out a few hours later and they're
finally done you know and you can just
break them up
you leave for a week and forgot that
somebody water your plants
[Music]
[ __ ] Constantine and Hell ass [ __ ]
over here
so if you don't know anything about FTX
you're clearly at this point I think you
guys understand you're not going to
learn anything serious about it from us
here's another picture of bankman free
thanks to Danny Saint
um
banking [ __ ] jewelry safe deposit box
Steam
even reverse mortgage Steen yes I've
heard of him
oh of the upper west side reverse
mortgagebergs yes I'm sorry I'm an
orthodox Smurf I'm not sure how that
works
my grandfather was the guy who invented
synthetic cdos oh wow very impressive I
put Gargamel back my grandfather was was
Ira overdraft fee
dude this is I have to keep this one up
because you're so weird yeah you had all
this money
apparently she went to school with him
am I correct with that Virgie okay so
she went to school with him and they and
then she he made her like the CFO CFO
right see I think it's CFO or CTO I
don't remember but anyway the company
CEO or CFO same difference she was on
the board she was on the board right she
was head [ __ ] in charge for some
[ __ ] reason so
now this is the part where I'm trying
you think her and jufro were like
traveling all over the world [ __ ]
like rabbits you imagine these two
[ __ ] gross mother they're [ __ ] on
like in the nicest hotel in Tangier
Morocco
they were all [ __ ] each other this is
true
shut up
Virgie Mercy didn't know this he's
joking yeah tell him about the orgies
it turns out that Sam bankman freed
owned a little island in the Bahamas
where him and this one and all of the
executives of [ __ ] uh have more Jesus
used to [ __ ] oh hey by the way you
remember that guy from Puerto Rico that
was that posted on Twitter and was like
there's a pedo ring that started up in
the Caribbean and they're going to frame
me and blah blah blah blah blah blah
yeah he was talking about FTX allegedly
yeah she's 30 years she's 30 years
didn't shut down it just went under new
management and locations yeah it just it
just went on the blockchain well I never
I never doubted that they just moved
that that type of thing you know what I
mean I I I I've worked for enough
[ __ ] uh nuisance nightclubs over the
years to know just on a lower level how
that works when you get shut down and
you're like we're already getting a new
liquor license and we have a new place
it's like a couple miles up we're just
gonna file a new LLC no we're not a
nuisance we're not a nuisance business
anymore
new names on the liquor license
so
now what I'm trying to understand here
is well number one verse yes they work
they're going from hotel to hotel and
you could tell they were there because
all the sheets have holes cut in them
um what what how did they how did he
lose the money
how did he lose the money yeah oh
because they were okay so this girl has
shoulders like a cheap hanger
did you put my shirt on a wire hanger
again no no I just sent it to Caroline
she said she's got she's got shoulders
that look like the [ __ ] hangers that
the dry cleaner give you your [ __ ] back
on you have to rip the paper off here
the same extra as the back of a
buffalo's ass
okay
ever been to a petting zoo that is a
[ __ ] hilarious joke
boy please subscribe to him uh fat
catboy please subscribe to Boogie
bumpers Rumble yeah subscribe to
subscribe to Boogie bumper please oh you
guys are [ __ ] murdering me these
these okay so anyway oh cheap tea quotes
we don't use stop losses an actual quote
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
this is crazy okay go ahead I'm sorry
sorry one of the big it's there's so
many reasons why this company went under
to be honest with you that was one of
them that MERS just said one of the
other ones was FTX at no point had any
BTC it had no Bitcoin in its accounts
none when you bought Bitcoin from them
they just threw the number up there and
said that you had it because they would
go and [ __ ] take the money out of it
but you never but you never actually you
never actually had it that's insane you
when you withdrew your Bitcoin from FTX
they physically went and bought Bitcoin
put it into your account for you that's
crazy you never there was never any
Bitcoin in FTX ever
and the Chinese God now here's the thing
but why you say that remember something
the second highest donor to the
Democratic party was all money that now
because of FTX and all these people now
the White House is signaling again
really hard that because their little
money laundering crypto money laundry
screen I would say didn't work it didn't
work because it got them it got it got a
bunch of now it's getting attention now
it's getting attention now they're going
to use the very thing they created to
make all this money because see they're
not going to give the money back to FDX
to fix everything no oh well you know
what they need to do regulate they're
going out going to try to regulate the
crypto Market because of something they
created themselves
that sounds fair
can we get this hottie off the screen
I'm just why you think she's too high
I'm gonna get all hot and bothered here
the [ __ ] has the she has the knees of a
yak bro even her knees are terrible like
God really was just cruel to this woman
hold on wait
yeah right you think your knees are bad
will you hear her beautiful laugh her
velvety oh God did God not even give her
a nice voice yeah definitely oh yeah so
it was a it was a weird summer for sure
um ma'am you're already the ugliest
thing I've ever seen but your Gollum
looking ass shouldn't be filming from
down to up okay
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
it sounds like one two
[Laughter]
that's what Sam Jewish named Bagel saw
when he was munching her box
did you come Sam Jewish Jewish name
bagel
yeah
somebody says she's another one that
belongs to Fraggle Rock
Palm farming was really the beginning of
it
um
are you the only one that talks later
you're going to hear from David
withdrall stain
[Laughter]
oh man the Jewish names have been fun
today she looks like she looks like the
first female writer SNL ever had
face concubine
sickle of the whole thing you're right
she's a she's one of the [ __ ] up a
Tina Fey [ __ ] up clone that came back
you know American Dad the little weird
one help me I can't walk what's that
guy's name I'm getting stronger I'm
getting stronger
I got it it's [ __ ] multiplicity she's
the [ __ ] one that puts Pizza in it
she's a clone of the Clone hold on hold
on
okay here it is
uh Billy Billy it's Billy she's like
[Laughter]
oh no
uh
Billy is his name he's part of the
program one of my success stories I used
to be six inches tall now I'm daddy's
favorite look at me what
oh my God
[Laughter]
Steve is so [ __ ] good oh my God